أريد شخصًا يوقع
عقدًا أطول من 18 شهرًا ، وأنا أعلم أنني
أريد التزامًا ،
أريد من هذا الشخص أن
يوحد مانشستر تحت جلده
ليحب تمامًا النادي الذي رأيناه
كل شخص نجح في
النادي
هم  لقد انتهيت بمجرد وجودهم هناك وما
زالوا يشعرون
أن هذا شيء
يمثل جزءًا كبيرًا من حياتي
أريد أن أريد هذا النوع من الالتزام
بيتر شميشيل هو بيتر
شميشيل يلقي باسمه في تلك اللحظة الثانية
لا أعتقد أن التدريب
هو مصدر قوتي ولكن ليس هناك شك في
أنني أحب أن أفعل شيئًا
مثيرًا للاهتمام تمامًا وأنت تعرف
من يعرف
أه ستتغير الكثير من الأشياء
في العام المقبل  أيضًا ، إنه
يتنحى عن شخص آخر ، حيث
سيكون هناك مجموعة جديدة من العيون
على كل شيء وربما إعداد جديد
يبحث في كيفية إنجاز الأشياء من
قبل
وكيف يمكن القيام بالأشياء في
المستقبل